[Music]
hey folks
welcome to the dark horse podcast live
stream
our i believe dr heather hines
that is indeed our 71st which is prime
prime again and i didn't see that coming
how could i have missed it it's
there's always more coming there's
always more coming okay
before we do anything before we get to
anything else i just want to say for
those people who are
watching this on youtube um
we are aware of the situation with my
hair
the need for a haircut we have a small
team of people working on
solutions to the problem and i'm not on
the team apparently
no no i've uh i've kept you out of it so
far if if needed we will call you in
i think i appreciate that um for those
of you who are listening to the audio
only version
my hair is perfect
all right yeah i just thought i'd
mention that at the top so uh you know
there was no
misunderstanding about where things
stand excellent so today we're going to
be talking a little bit about
trees and mood and their effect on mood
and lockdowns and specifically
uh schools being closed and sports being
out and their their effects on lockdowns
and some about uh some council culture
going on in music
and we might get to polar bears and
uh you've got a few things to say at the
very end of the hour that we'll save
uh we'll save for that i think they fit
very very well with uh where
where things are yeah and we would just
say as as usual
um please consider supporting the
podcast supporting us at either of our
patreons where you can find access to
discord server
and um and access to longer
private conversations so um without
further ado should we should we embark
on talking about
uh trees and nature yeah let's do that
trees in nature and mood all right
so there's this uh this article that
came out on the very
last day i think although i'm not now
seeing that of last year
called urban street tree biodiversity
and antidepressant prescriptions
by marcel at all and um
the you know very first two sentences of
the abstract actually i'll just uh
um i'll read those growing urbanization
is a threat to both mental health and
biodiversity
street trees are an important
biodiversity component of urban green
space but little is known about their
effects on mental health
so um the the very short
version of what they found is that
uh people living within a hundred meters
300 plus feet
or so of um of what what are called
street trees this is a term of art i
guess in urban planning where you know
trees on that strip in front of
you know between between residences and
or sidewalks and streets
people whose homes are within 100 meters
328 or so feet
of street trees
have marginally lower antidepressant use
but if you control for socioeconomic
status
which is to say if you look only at
those people with lower socioeconomic
status
you actually we actually find this this
paper finds
a remarkable and this is you know this
is correlative of course
um a remarkable apparent effect
on antidepressant use and so
specifically the line is
indeed i don't know where it is in the
paper but i have it my notes here
indeed under high density of street
trees at 100 meters or closer
individuals with low socioeconomic
status had a similar probability of
being prescribed antidepressants
as individuals with high socioeconomic
status
so that to me is kind of staggering that
everyone who thinks about these sorts of
things knows and is well established in
a robust substantial and rigorous
literature that
socioeconomic status is correlated with
health outcomes
right um the richer you are in general
the healthier you are and of course
there are lots of exceptions to that but
um there are concerted efforts you know
good faith careful concerted efforts to
try to figure out how to break that that
it's you know it's very hard to
to to break poverty and of course there
are many people trying to do that as
well but
um there are an additional set of sort
of public health efforts to try to
figure out what
you know if poverty what can we do
to try to ensure try to make sure that
being poor does not inherently uh
make you ill unhealthy
and this finding suggests that um simply
living fairly close to trees
may may seriously reduce the risk of at
least this one measure of health which
is mental health which is depression
so uh let me help unpack this here this
is a paper i have not read so i'm going
to just
uh riff off of what i'm hearing and see
if i can make sense of it
the point is that actually and so there
are obviously
multiple levels of entanglement here and
statistics are the tool for untangling
which thing
is actually correlated to what and if
done in the context of a proper
hypothesis
it allows you to assess what might be
causal
indeed and what we have here is an
indication
that socioeconomic status
which is known to have a positive effect
on mental health that can be seen
in being less likely to be prescribed
drugs
for depression as underst as as
found in other pieces of research that
is not the research that these people
did
this is that is uh a pre-existing
research already established
that if we then look within people of
socio
low socioeconomic status that living
within was it 100 meters of
100 meters of trees um actually results
in them
catching up to levels of high
uh economic well-being so with regard
to not being prescribed antidepressants
at um as higher rates
as you would expect simply by virtue of
their socioeconomic status
which suggests i will just one caveat
here is that this research did not set
out to did not hypothesize socioeconomic
status
being a differential variable going in
they uh they knew
of course that low socioeconomic status
um
is tends to be um associated with with
worse health outcomes
but upon looking at their data they saw
a marginally significant result with
regard to
proximity to trees and not being
prescribed antidepressants at high rates
across
all across all demographics actually but
when they then
parsed it out by socioeconomic cl um
status
that result became highly significant so
for the large fraction of our audience
that is deeply interested in the
philosophy of science they will spot
right away
then that what has happened here is that
this paper in testing one hypothesis
has made an observation which leads to
the next hypothesis which is now in need
of its own test in order to know
whether it is scientifically supported
and so
fascinating though that what they appear
to have discovered suggests the
following model
which is there is something that causes
a breakdown in normal function if we
imagine that depression is in some ways
a breakdown of normal function or at
least depression that is to the
extent that it results in a prescription
that that is a dysfunction and that that
dysfunction
is uh triggered by
something in the change of socioeconomic
status from
high to low and that it can be regained
by proximity to trees alone is
fascinating which doesn't say it's the
only thing that would do that but it
does say
that it's something that we would see
now of course the thing i'm fascinated
by and maybe maybe the paper addresses
it
is that some part of us
knows that tree-lined streets are good
that's why they're in the rich
neighborhoods and that is why they are
very rarely found
in impoverished neighborhoods it's
actually interesting
um one thing they do says this this
research um
was conducted in leipzig germany uh and
um there
is similar but not exactly comparable
research that's been done in london
that came to the same conclusion but it
was uh if i'm if memory serves that
research was different and that they
were looking only at the aggregate as
opposed to very
very much particular households that are
living within proximity to street trees
and antidepressant use
um but so you know there's a there's a
growing weight of evidence that finds
this
and there is the widespread expectation
and i i still believe it must be true
in many places that richer neighborhoods
tend to have more trees
but at least in their research at least
here in leipzig they didn't find that
they actually did not find that the
lower income neighborhoods had fewer
trees
okay but that may i've i will be shocked
if it cannot be demonstrated in the us
that uh the wealthy neighborhoods are
much more likely to
to be tree-lined or the density of their
tree lining is greater or whatever it is
for lots of different reasons for
one i mean we could probably list a
dozen reasons that should be so
one people's positive association with
trees causes the
houses on those streets to be more
expensive which means that people of
higher socioeconomic
status can afford them the fact that the
tax base
is uh somewhat local is is going to mean
that there are more resources to do
something that actually costs
more like maintaining trees rather than
simple pavement so there are lots of
reasons that you would expect that
correlation
now what the heck is the trees okay
sorry go on well just that you would
expect to find them on the
fancier streets for lots and because
there are lots of reasons we have to be
careful here
that there's not some third correlate
and that this has very little to do with
trees
well that's a possibility it is a
possibility um one of the ways
this research uh differs from all but a
couple of pieces of research that came
before
is that there's been a lot of talking
about green space about the value of
green space about being near
you know either wild nature semi-wild
nature parks etc
and they specifically looked at street
trees which
uh in their language uh as an advantage
in that they can be retrofitted
into neighborhoods that even though
you're right that it of course takes
you know some doing to plant them and
then some maintenance
and that especially if you're planting
the wrong species of trees that would
require a lot of irrigation or something
in order to keep them going you know
once they're past sapling stage
that they would be less likely to
persist in neighborhoods where there
weren't a lot of resources
but um well that i guess
well so what i would love to know is
one prediction of this if if the if the
correlation is due to causation
then you would expect that neighborhoods
in which trees had been added
that you would see a difference in
historical prescription rates over that
time that would be a great result
that would be what's called a matched
pairs that would be
image pairs experimental design
experimental design which would allow
you to specifically say aha we see a
decrease
after a decrease in antidepressant
prescription
uh after the addition of trees in these
neighborhoods i will say
um a couple couple other things one
intuitively this result
i probably sounds more right to you and
me
than it deserves on its merits because
because this is a complex
um set of phenomena in which trees are
liable to be correlated to dozens of
other things and therefore it could be
something else that's
lurking in the data and this would
evaporate if you tested the tree
hypothesis
directly right this is more intuitive to
you and me because you and i
have some kind of i would argue
unnatural level of need for this i think
you and i
would accept a huge decrease in quality
of life
to live in a place that you know looked
right out the windows
um that is to say um our values are such
that other
other changes in quality of life that
other people would rank more highly uh
as important to them uh we would accept
so long as we still had the trees out
the window yeah or you know or i would
say and you know this is
um you alluded to this early
early in this conversation but there
will certainly be uh ecosystems
in in which some cities are uh where
trees isn't the thing
right like it's and it may well be that
all humans would
you know would enjoy seeing a tree but
if you know tree-lined streets
in l.a for instance um are a different
phenomenon because
la happens to be in a place that doesn't
really natively have much in the way of
trees
and so you know i would i would predict
that access to some sorts of things that
would actually
be relevant and natural outside of your
window
um would do something similar and you
know the obvious thing is
is water yeah right um you know
coastlines rivers creeks
lakes ponds um any of that and of course
as as it is well well established
those pieces of real estate of course
are always
or are always belonging to people with
higher socioeconomic status well i want
to come back to the question of whether
or not we might be on the cusp of a
change here as a result
of um what covid has forced us to learn
which we probably should have known
anyway but um but i do agree
i think trees are certainly if the model
that you and i
are going to intuit from this is right
then trees are a proxy it's one of
dozens of things that could work and
almost certainly not the best of them
right so what do you why what do you why
do you think that
um because well personally
i would guess that there is something
about the staticness of trees and
trees are not perfectly static
especially deciduous trees
are you know dynamic at one time scale
and you know
trees blow in the wind and all of that
but
that there are lots of things so if i
just take myself as a model
right it's cool to see trees out the
window right
but it's like a hundred times as cool to
see
squirrels in the trees right so the the
the dynamism of
animals outside that raise questions at
a different time scale is
you know it's positive imagine i imagine
it has a sudoku-like effect on the mind
if you pay attention to the squirrels
like effect that's an interesting phrase
um all right so i
i'm with you on that but i actually
suspect that
um you know specifically squirrels and
trees might be a negative for a lot of
people
um you know we've we've joked about you
know
wanting more squirrels that you know
kind of wanting squirrel monkeys you
know even in temperate trees and such
and now we're not gonna go
introducing species where they don't
belong but um
i think that that many people especially
died in the wool urbanites can
can accept the grace and beauty of a
tree and get
a little freaked out by something that's
scurrying around in it
i think squirrels evoke something
different for people but anyway i'm sure
there are some people
who i know there are some people who
don't like squirrels there may be
um and you know people who are
trying to feed birds often don't like
squirrels for other reasons but
this is different you're not hanging out
with all the urbanites who really don't
like it when things run around or
they're not people
right i guess that's true but um but i
would also
argue that there's something um
there is an underappreciated disaster
in uh light pollution and noise
pollution
and so what we don't what we don't
remember
until it's absent is how different
things are mentally
when you can't hear a road right i was
actually so i
as you know i i did greg ellis's the
respondent podcast yesterday and it's
not out yet but
we were taught he and i were talking
about exactly this the
the value of a night sky where you can
actually see the milky way
and the value of a soundscape where you
can actually hear the birds
or the creek or whatever it is but it's
not the cars
or the honking or the or the
anthropogenic thing
which we learn to tune out i mean
ish not perfectly and you and i are very
sensitive to it because we often go to
places where you
you know we go to great lengths it turns
out that
um i mean to take two examples
or three examples the field station
la selva in sarapaki costa rica
you can hear trucks on the road which is
very sad because in many ways this is
a quite intact piece of forest in which
you'll see
all of the you know including things
that require uh undisturbed habitat like
you know bushmasters are still there so
it's really very intact forest but
and it's probably one of the two most
important
uh field field stations than neotropics
that have established a lot of what we
think we know
about neotropical ecology and so the
proxy the fact that you can hear the
road that it's so close
um you know renders those data that
research
at least at least all that research
warrants an asterisk at some level
right for anything where that might be a
relevant factor it's
important to consider but um i would say
if we compare this to your
primary field site in madagascar nosy
mangaby the island
off of the island of madagascar by
virtue of the primitiveness
of the uh civilization on land there are
obviously cars driving around but
they're far from
on madagascar on madagascar not on nosy
mangaby
so the point is there's the occasional
boat that comes by but it really is
insulated from those kinds of things
um not flying over you do occasionally
see stuff fly over
fly in um very occasionally there at
least you know it's been
gosh it's been 20 years since i've been
there at this point but
um also i mean just because it's right
at the western edge of the indian ocean
there's just not right there's not a lot
of reason to fly over it
i was going to compare this to bci where
i did my field work which is a very
first world first-rate field station by
virtue of the technology available for
science but by virtue of the fact that
it's in
lake gatun in the panama canal it is
insulated from
the noises of the outside world with an
interesting exception
the boats there's plenty of planes
flying overhead obviously plenty of
planes
on bci boats go by in the canal
and the weird thing maybe not so weird
sonically but it's weird that the
difference is the stark is that you
by and large don't hear them during the
day and at night the sound travels much
better and maybe you're also more
attuned to it but there is the sense of
like
you can see the boats going silently by
in the day um
and then at night you actually hear them
you know
god is there going to be something about
um
the the coldness of the air and the
amount of water that is held in believe
so
i believe so um and then i was there and
and maybe also
sensory uh you know what else you were
tuned to that you that that are hearing
it's
gets ratcheted up at night when our eyes
can't do as good a job
yes doing at doing sensory
interpretation of our environment
that's true but because i was very much
interested in this pattern while i was
there i
listened very carefully when i saw ships
go by seemingly silently in the day to
see if i could find the noise and in
general not
so there i think there's definitely a
physical thing but i wanted to compare
all of these things
to tippatini in yasuni where we've spent
time my recollection is the first
week in tiputini we literally
did not see a single plane fly over and
it's certainly
way too remote to hear anything else
right and so the idea of a place on
earth where actually
you don't see any evidence of anything
from the outside yeah is
a level of insulation i mean there's
there's a way in which nozi manga beam
my field site in madagascar is
is more remote um but there's also a way
in which it's less
that it is uh five kilometers at the
moment given where the sea levels are
now
uh from the the mainland of madagascar
and the town of mar and sutra and marin
cetera
is itself not connected by road for much
of the year because the roads get washed
out on the regular
every year and so and you know the the
and it's it's not a it's not a giant
town but it's a town with a regular
rice market which is the you know most
rice and coal or most of what people
charcoal or most of what people are
buying if they have any money at all to
buy things
um and you know it's five five
kilometers away the vast majority of
people don't have any way to get there
um you know they're always on on most
days at least in
the late 90s you would see a perogue or
two
you know one of these dugout canoes uh
with a fisherman
um who was out for the day getting fish
for his family
and very occasionally you get a spice
boat coming by
because this is uh this is where a lot
of the world's vanilla
is grown in the in the um mishwa
peninsula
and a lot of a lot of cloves as well and
so you have these
malagasy spice boats who are who are
interested in
stopping at nosy mangaby on the way down
the coast to
access one of the bigger court the
bigger ports uh and that's you know
that's definitely
a strange you know a strange thing from
the outside world when you get a bunch
of
usually naked sailors spilling off these
boats that smell like vanilla and cloves
what are they doing right yeah okay so
back to the paper though yeah the um
the point i wanted to make is that i bet
there are a bunch of things
that have a calming calibrating effect
on the mind that you know that just
simply at
base remind you that you are somehow
embedded in nature and that you can get
very involved in the human stuff but the
other thing
you know is wonderfully indifferent to
your social concerns
right um and so you know brooks
the sky um animals that
surprise you and
essentially point towards questions
about what they're up to and why they're
doing it now and
and all of that and i realize most
people aren't uh consciously tuned into
those questions but i do think part of
what's being measured here is
anything that suggests a connection to
that other thing is probably good and it
would be interesting to know
how much it's you know trees are the
thing because
i don't know because they're uh capable
of being in any
habitat and all but yeah or you know
also a horizon
um line that tells you that it's um you
know that that
most of us find sort of a twinkling
horizon pretty in a way
but especially a jagged horizon that
suggests mountains that
doesn't have lights on it brings to mind
a very different sense of like that
there if i could get there
you know i would i would i would be in
nature and you know here in the pacific
northwest
we've not only got these these lines of
of mountains running all the way from bc
from british columbia down to california
but they're punctuated by volcanoes
and so um you know here we can
we have depending on where you are in in
portland you can see
hood and um adams and helens
and um you know farther north you also
get um
you also get mount rainier and farther
north baker and i know i'm forgetting at
least one but you know these
really these just iconic
and you know mount st helens isn't that
beautiful anymore because it blew its
top
in what 1980 81 one of the two um
but the rest of them you know in a in a
line up here it's the cascades and then
emerging
from the top of a mountain range is this
is this
vulcan volcanic cone like oh that tells
me
something about what's out there and
it's not any it's not us
yeah it's not us it's not us yeah if
there's one thing we don't control it's
volcanoes
that's for sure yes yep all right so
uh are we going somewhere else no no
okay so let's see there were a few other
things i wanted to say about this paper
um here's another uh
quote that zach i'm just reading off my
my screen so don't show it
another component of dose by which they
mean how many trees and how close
so they looked they they were also
interested in not just
uh whether amount of trees um
you know proximity to any trees amount
of trees and also they were looking at
what's called species richness
which is to say diversity of trees tree
species
another component of dose is to
understand for whom urban green space
has the strongest effect
certain people are at greater risk for
depression in germany
again this is just where the research
was done in germany women people with
low socioeconomic status and unemployed
people are at greater risk for
depression
and are more likely to be prescribed
antidepressants previous research has
investigated whether exposure to green
space could be protective against or
moderate
or or moderate health inequalities
so um this you know the whole paper
causes a person to think about
depression but
this specifically caused me to think
about depression because i thought well
okay separately it is known that
women are more prone to depression than
men um and let's just let's table that
discussion for the moment about why that
might be
but the other things that were here were
where was it
low so's people with low serious
economic status as we've already been
talking about
unemployed people well
if we imagine that depression as
something that has been
in humans for a very long time and has
complexity and has
variable cost is in fact adaptive
um under what conditions and you know
not to say that there aren't
pathological forms of depression that
really create problems for people
but you know what conditions under what
conditions
might feeling depressed be adaptive
sufficient
to cause you to change your conditions
if you have any control at all over them
and thus create an environment in which
you would no longer have cause to be
depressed if you are of low
socioeconomic status
if you have low unemployment and another
one was um
they they just looked at personality
characteristics of optimist versus
pessimist
like well um if if you are
apparently if you have a pessimistic
view on the world you are more likely to
be prescribed antidepressants
that both seems obvious and also a
little bit backwards because maybe you
have a pessimistic view on the world
because your opportunities suck because
you haven't been
you know you you you haven't been able
to find
or the world has not provided you an
ability to make opportunities
with which you can change your
environment so i want to
uh argue that this is a place for the
dichotomy we
very often have things where we name
something
based on the pathological form yes right
and so i think the point is there is
a an adaptive state here and i think
randy nessie has done
wonderful work in this area and people
ought to look him up if they want to
understand it but the basic point is
look
if you you know just simple biological
um
predicament if you have no
prospects with which to enhance your
position in the world
then what you can do is you can minimize
what you're burning of what you've got
right so not being active in the world
not being out
spending money not being out wasting
calories whatever you're doing might be
the right thing now does that feel good
does it look good probably not
the pathological version then becomes
you know
paralytic depression or depression that
is uncorrelated to what prospects you
might actually have that blinds you to
them or something like that but we
should be
careful not to assume that the entire
landscape is just a malfunction
when it almost certainly isn't i did
want to go back and correct one
thing though i have also heard and read
that women are somewhat more prone to
depression
and i've always thought that this was
incorrect that it's really it's
it's playing different roles that men
are too busy causing women to become
depressed and so it's like a
yin-yang relationship so the way you
would test that experimentally is to
look at straight women
versus lesbians yes
and what would we find if we did that do
you have any idea
this is this is your game man
i just gave you another shovel all right
well i'm gonna go uh
check with a bunch of lesbians and see
if i come up with anything
useful on this time do you get back to
me yeah so well of course
of course um yeah i mean the question
the sex
differences in various um uh
so-called mood disorders um is an
interesting topic but just not
one that i'm prepared to go into in any
depth today
um let's see there was at least one more
thing
that i wanted to talk about here oh that
they
you know they're using this proxy for um
for depression which is antidepressant
use right
and that's in one way a great proxy
because it doesn't require self reports
it doesn't you know of of mood of you
know and
and then assessing with people you don't
know at all with whom you don't have a
long-standing clinical relationship for
instance whether or not they are in fact
depressed
um and so it's you know it's it's
quantitative it's actually
a pretty good simple metric and those
are fairly hard to come by
just like measuring you know having
databases on street trees
is not a perfect overlap for how many
trees there might be what if people have
trees in their backyard that doesn't
that doesn't get counted by this but
it's a pretty good simple proxy
um but it does raise this issue of
are antidepressants helping and you know
we're
again i want to we're going to do this
it's in some more depth at some point
but
um i i will say that i think that there
are very very very few people for whom
antidepressants
do seem to help not just
right away but persistently but there
is abundant evidence that
antidepressants
are themselves causal of many problems
that they are themselves
addictive such that uh it can become
impossible to get off of them
and have uh have anything like
uh coherence in your moods and and life
um going forward and that they you know
as as we've talked about a little bit
before on here
this idea of um there are a whole bunch
of people walking around with a chemical
imbalance in their brain
is about as ludicrous as suddenly in the
20th century
all human you know a majority of mostly
mostly rich humans
started needing orthodontia because our
teeth are all terrible
because our because jeans are driving
our teeth to not be in the right
position right right right
yeah i totally agree with this and um
i i want to point out that i think
this work is effectively revealing
a very very general pattern in other
words
what are the chances that if you
[Music]
you know if the real question is um
are modern living circumstances
healthy for people right and you
zone in or you zoom in on two
characteristics here's an unhealthy
thing
depression bad enough that you need
drugs for it or you need treatment
right and here's a thing that we've
gotten farther from trees
right what are the chances if we just
compare these two things that lo and
behold we will find that actually trees
may be playing a
really positive role for people who live
near them right and so
so yours like pick pick almost anything
that we historically always had a close
relationship with and have less of a
close relationship now
and another character that seems new to
the 20th or 21st century
in terms of something that people are
experiencing
and one of them's going up one of them's
going down let's see
if we move the the one that was going
down
up we can't move the other one down
right and so
my prediction if you just propose the
experiment without naming trees or
depression is you're going to find
correlations they will be very very weak
because there are so many of these
things and they will all
come combined to make the effect but
what this particular thing is saying is
either this is a special relationship
which i doubt
or that the point is even a small amount
of contact that you retain to your
former
uh self that lived in close proximity to
trees
is enough to restore a sense of balance
and so anyway this does
point uh very much to the
theme of our book which we
finished this week yep um and i should
say
we finished it this week we are sitting
here
together still more or less smiling to
each other
um you did not so much as
contact a lawyer about divorce as far as
i know is that
far as you know that's fine
all right well anyway i think this is a
testament um to something very popular
submitting it
the final the final draft to our editor
i did tell her that neither dishes nor
marriages were broken
this is wonderful i mean this you know
this isn't just uh
co-authoring a book you and i have
survived our marriage has survived
riding tandem bicycles together we have
lived in a tent together
for for months we tandem
cox these are these are marriage killers
right there and uh
none of that was as hard as this
i know i'm really sorry but in any case
in any case
the same for now the
vast majority of people watching who are
like why did he just take the hit for
that like
i will say that when it's uh tandem
kayaks or bicycles or sharing a tent
we are equally responsible for the
problems
and the the chaos but um the problems on
this
yeah were not shared equally no they
were not surety okay
but in any case the theme of the book
the theme of the book
is about hyper novelty that is to say
all the changes
that the world inflicts on us moderns
and
the consequence and i just want to point
out that in some sense
the lesson of this work about the trees
is that something else has been driving
the uh structures of our lives
yeah we have been moved overwhelmingly
into cities we have been
moved away from our families we have
been moved
uh we have been uh blocked from seeing
the night sky we have been forced to
process noise that our minds must throw
out in order for us to think straight
we have been got blue leds in every room
in our house
blue leds we sit under fluorescent
lights every manner of distortion
is there and the point is a there are
trade-offs right
is there something good to moving into a
larger population
sure you might find people whose
interests match yours better or with
whom you're better
positioned to collaborate just because
it's a larger population but at what
cost
and so we never get to the at what cost
we see
the value of doing this that and the
other and we are
finally finally finally beginning to
recognize
the massive cost of just simply not
knowing
that there was a connection that
actually your physical proximity to
something like trees
might have a major impact through no
mechanism that we can specify
on your sense of your own prospects in
the world
right that is an amazing fact and if we
ever got good
at sorting out all of the various
contributing factors
we might immediately be able to give the
world a huge
raise in terms of well-being by simply
reducing the negative impacts you could
probably reduce the negative impact of
most of these things
by 80 percent for a yes very small
fraction of
uh the cost you could keep most of the
benefit and
wouldn't it be wonderful if we were less
insane because
everything that we are surrounded by is
at odds with us
i do i do like again the idea of
retrofitting trees i think
one of the reasons that this research
caught my eye this week
um was that you know unlike
a call for um you know 100 acre park in
the middle of an extent
urban landscape like where what else has
to give a ton of
stuff else would have to give unless
there's already a park that's just
fallen into disarray
whereas uh
many many neighborhoods have concrete
that could be and is it's not free and
it's not even that cheap but it's
pretty cheap uh to put in street trees
compared to a lot of the other kind of
green space
that um that many of us want well
i i agree with that and part of the
problem is that we cannot escape
the sense that you know these are the
cities
but these cities were put where they are
and constructed the way they are
because something was prioritized over
human well-being now at the time
we didn't understand as much about human
well-being and we couldn't
now we can and so in some sense if
you're if you're scratching your head
how can we people are so broken and so
confused
and um you know and are in need of
you know surgery and having tension put
on their teeth
and uh you know all of these things the
answer is okay well
this is all true for us right
how can we not make it true for another
generation these people that have yet to
be born
haven't been hurt yet and so going
forward we could reorganize things and
the fact is no
city should look like this you shouldn't
be intermingled
with with vehicles everywhere right the
vehicles may be necessary right
but there's a way to organize things so
that the point is the vehicles get you
where you need to go
um at a gross level something else your
own power
or something else that is not
destructive dangerous and all of that
transports you the rest of the way you
are surrounded by green you could
imagine
a version of a city that was much more
hospitable and
um you know it's terrible that we don't
think in these terms
i will say that our new hometown
portland oregon um
does a really good job of this at least
um at least on the west side and i think
much of the east side too but the the
west
the west hills which is rolling her uh
then the flats
on the east side of the willamette um
have
has a ton of parks and uh one of the
things that i have done
during the last year of lockdowns when
um
we've both traveled less than i think
i've been fewer places than i have in
any other adult year of my life
i i crave exploration and adventure and
travel and you know any day that i find
myself standing someplace i've never
stood before
um is is a win for me and it's been
harder and harder to accomplish
um while being in a city but not a city
that we've lived in for very long and so
um just even yesterday actually i had
you know a half an hour
after um being somewhere before i had to
get home to do this podcast
um and so i went to one of the coffee
shops that i like
and then just you know this is you can
use tech to find
nature right i just googled up parks
near me and that you know
x near me feature that everyone who uses
google i think
knows on their phones knows exists um
probably usually you think you know
gas stations near me or you know
restaurants near me but parks near me
is wonderful and i knew that there was
this giant park
about a half a mile away but i know that
park and that's not where i wanted to go
i wanted to see if there were
a little pocket park near me and there
was like you know a tenth of a mile away
and so i walked through a residential
neighborhood that i never seen before
and you know saw a couple dogs i'd never
seen before and ended up a little park
with um with yes a lot of trees and uh
you know a playground with even some
kids playing oh my god they're all
masked but okay
and um and that was that i didn't know
and i wouldn't have done in that case
you know i would never have driven
down a series of little residential
streets um to a dead-end road
um absent being able to say parks near
me anyone
uh so that that is another way to sort
of
add value to your daily life i think
yeah absolutely
and i do think that uh parks you know
obviously this didn't test parks
but exactly parks parks works people's
people love them
and uh they have the same effect on the
mind for sure
um just one more thing
about two more things about this um
article before we move on
um i mentioned that they looked at
species richness like okay
trees close good but um how about
diversity of trees the number of species
of trees and they've
they found um that didn't matter like it
didn't have an effect on
mood and it reminded me of something
that steve hermann
said to me the last time i saw him which
would have been early 2019 and
we talked a bit about steve hermann on
episode 17
actually and i know which one it was
because
episode 17 back on may 23rd
of last year was when we talked about
the evergreen
fiasco because it was the anniversary
and
steve herman died early in covid not
from covet i think but he was a
nearly founding member of the evergreen
faculty an extraordinary naturalist an
extraordinary
ornithologist who had all of his
students learn for instance the grinnell
journaling
style for for natural history and i
was actually i had just begun um
interviewing him uh with regard to
some of the wondrous things that
evergreen had done early in its time
when we were
trying to talk we were thinking about
trying to figure out how to create
a kind of higher ed that would be robust
to make that clearer
you and i were not part of evergreens
founded we were tiny children
so at a time when you and i were talking
about how
now in the present to make uh
higher ed more robust you were
interviewing steve herman about what he
had seen back towards the founding of
the college
in early 2019 which i thought i said ah
sorry
you could just no no maybe it was
unclear
i i missed i missed the 2019. okay um so
two years ago or so um i was with him in
his um
in his living room in rural
southwestern washington and he said
something to the effect of
um too many people don't know that there
are a lot of kinds of trees
and when he said that i thought oh come
on like everyone knows like a difference
between a pine tree and a maple tree and
he said yeah kind of but
within gymnosperms which is um you know
all the trees with needles
or um people don't really know the
difference
and um you know probably most people
know maple and oak
because they've got these really iconic
leaf shapes but also just because like
we build things out of them right like
we we know the trees that have utility
to us
and um and for him
he always like his his style of
education was really about
you know drilling down the on the detail
and having students really know
you know what species of bird that is
and what species of plant that
is and from there people were able to
find their own meaning and i think
um that is you know that's that's very
rare and i don't think it's necessary to
get value
but it is something that that struck me
that it's probably true that a lot of
people don't actually
walk around noticing that there are a
lot of different kinds of trees it's
just like yeah there's trees
yes and can you go back to the title of
the article
the title of the article is urban street
tree biodiversity and antidepressant
prescriptions
yeah so that title is actually wrong
because although they studied the
biodiversity they concluded that it had
no
impact well they i mean they they looked
at it and they that title doesn't say
yeah what the relationship is i agree
but it also does
highlight something that they found no
correlation with
um so anyway as to uh steve's
point yep and a title for either the
project that educates people on this
or a better title for that paper what's
it to ya
i mean right absolutely and to those six
of you who got that reference
congratulations
well done uh yeah is the genus
the latin genus for uh use i think uh no
it's just
it's juniper's yeah but user type of
juniper no no they're definitely
different oh that's texas texas yes
obviously
yes um and
okay just it's just this it's an
interesting paper so we're spending a
fair bit of time on it even though a lot
of these things are
little um quote from the paper this
finding is supported by other studies
that found abundance of a taxonomic
group
but not its species richness affects
mental health and well-being
so this had me wondering how many clades
that might apply to so
what they're saying is you get a lot of
something around and that makes you feel
better but it doesn't
really matter if there's diversity of
that thing and i thought you know for a
lot of people and i think steve would
steve herman would resonate with this
two birds right like a lot of people
like like the idea of birds around but
you know i know when i go out in the
morning and listen to the don chorus
um i'm you know a hundredth the birder
that steve was
but i know that it is more interesting
to me when i hear a diversity of
of bird song and bird call that i know
are coming from different species
you know and i and then i can infer
about mixed foraging flocks and about
different behaviors and like i can i can
sort of add
add to my model of what it is that is
out of view about what is actually going
on as opposed to if i just heard you
know if i just heard crows which i love
or if i just heard chickadees um it's
it's a
it's a more depopperate natural history
and therefore a more
popular story that you could tell but um
i don't think the same thing would hold
like
more you know more trees um but it
doesn't matter if you've got a diversity
of them
better mood more birds better mood more
leeches better mode more sharks better i
don't think so i don't think it holds
for all clades
well antelope antelope would antelope
improve your mood
antelopes would would improve my mood
yeah i'm gonna have to look at whether
antelopes is how you say i think
antelope
it's i think it's antelope antelope i
think you're right um but no
or actually to use our younger son's um
pluralization scheme it might be
antelope
and yeah that's good you're right no i
i'm not so sure about this i think
actually it does hold across clades and
i this is admittedly an anecdote but uh
we will return to this but um
earlier this week uh actually yesterday
i was
in a i was enjoying the sun i was out in
a local nature reserve sitting
and i detected that i was being
bit by a mosquito and i looked at it in
horror and i realized
it was a type of mosquito i've never
seen before
and so that made me feel good and then i
killed it and i felt even better so yes
it elevated my mood
but that actually that runs counter to
this you you were interested in the
richness
of the species richness of the mosquito
of the local mosquito populations but
not in the quantity no i was interested
in vanquishing this mosquito and the
fact that it was a
novel foe made me even happier
excellent okay um and then just one more
line from this paper uh which
is referenced to a different paper
indeed the most common way people
experience nature is through a window
so i find this sad but it also helps
explain why
they got the results that they did that
street trees that products that within
being within 100 meters of a tree
you being having your home with 100
meters of trees
is is predictive of
being less likely to be on
antidepressants
and you know mostly people are
experiencing
whatever nature they're experiencing
through a window
i'm sure the benefits would be higher uh
if they were actually out in the air
with all of their senses attuned and all
of this but um
amazing that the benefit can be can
be gotten simply by viewing it through
a pane of glass yeah that is amazing
that the effect um
persists even through that low bandwidth
channel yeah and i will say i think part
of you know part of the problem is that
people lose
you know you know at one level it's
really dumb it's pretty easy to go out
and access nature
on the other hand if you kind of don't
know where to go in order to
encounter nature that's actually worth
looking at yeah
or you don't know how to interact with
it because
it didn't happen to be a feature of the
way your family did things or whatever
it's not that obvious and um it's
you know it's a pity but it's something
we need to consider which is well how do
you onboard somebody into this process
that
it is simply assumed you know we all
know where to go and what to do and
we're choosing not to
um that's silicon valley speak meets
nature yep
all right that hurt i'm taking it back
it's just corporate speak i don't know
um
yeah too uh in i
didn't i didn't mean to stop you in your
tracks there
yes um all right uh i will i will think
more carefully for
before speaking in the future and even
after that
great all right um
so before before we go on to talking
about uh mumford and sons which you want
to talk about some
uh i want to read just a couple
of sections from this um remarkable
very long pro-publica piece that came
out and we'll link to it
as we as we do to the main things we
talk about in the
in the show notes such that people can
read it themselves so this is about
um basically suicides in young people
under strict
lockdowns and
let me see hold on
and i don't know where it went oh there
we go
um here we go if you could show my
screen zach thank you so this is um
published just a few days ago alec
mcgillis in propublica
and it comes under the title the last
year what the pandemic cost
teenagers with the subtitle in hobbes
new mexico the high school closed and
football was canceled well just across
the state line in texas
students seem to be living nearly normal
lives here's how pandemic school
closures exact their emotional toll on
young people
so zack if i may for a moment um
i'll read one section from just from my
screen and then i'll have you give
give it back in a minute zach so and the
quote and the psychological stress that
the pandemic has produced for so many
americans of all ages
is unlike so many more acute crises that
we might experience in life
said nick allen a professor of clinical
psychology at the university of oregon
quote this is quoting nick allen there's
a difference between a stressor that
makes your life unpleasant and
intolerable and a stressor that takes
away good things he said
for a lot of people the stressor that
covid represents is one that takes away
good things
you can't go to sporting events you
can't see your friends you can't go to
parties
it's not necessarily that you're
experiencing abuse although some may be
what's happening is that we're taking
away high points in people's lives that
give them reward and meaning
that may have an effect over time the
initial response is not as difficult as
something that's stressful but over time
the anhedonia the loss of pleasure is
going to drive you down a lot more
which i think is critical
um and then i'm going to read three
paragraphs from
nearer the end in which the author let
me just set it up first the author is
visiting
the teacher the favorite teacher of a
young band
a young man named cooper who was
apparently healthy and well-adjusted and
beloved and he was
a star quarterback and he committed
suicide
um and it was stunning to everyone like
people did not believe it when they
heard
his name and he was not the first and
just a little bit
in by way of setup that new mexico has
been
um in sort of extreme lockdown for
almost a year at this point and
has um you know shut down schools and
most school sports and all of this
whereas just over the border
here where this is happening in texas um
the government has mostly let local
jurisdictions decide
um decide as as they want to
and so um let's see this
last here we go these three paragraphs
my last visit in hobbs that's the town
in new mexico
was to the home of jennifer espinoza
cooper's favorite teacher
when i entered her bungalow espinoza a
friendly woman in her 40s said that i
should feel welcome to take my mask off
because she had already been through a
serious case of copen19 several weeks
earlier
this startled me but not nearly as much
as what she told me next
that soon after her own illness her
partner of 18 years abe had died of what
had strongly resembled cobat 19
though his initial test had come back
negative he had been away from hobbs at
the time working an oil field job in
odessa texas
and a co-worker he had shared a truck
with later tasted tested positive
abe died on november 30th at the age of
49 before she could see him
and then cooper the quarterback had died
a week later
it had been a terrible month and it had
left her uncertain about the best course
for the hobbes schools and sports teams
as the school year started she had been
among the majority of teachers who were
willing to return to classrooms
this had not only been confirmed for her
she saw how poorly the remote learning
was going
not only did most students leave their
cameras off some wouldn't even turn on
their microphones
i can't see them i can't even hear them
she said they didn't want to talk
but then she herself had gotten the
virus she wasn't sure where and its
severity had hit home
even before her partner's death she had
swung the other way on reopening
now cooper's death was making her
reconsider again
if it would prevent another cooper then
definitely yes she said
we just have to weigh the good and the
bad do we fear everyone coming back and
possibly getting covered
or do we fear losing another student
more
so you had not heard that before no um
it makes me think a lot of things um and
it's hard for me to separate it from
uh what the world looks like as people
are
experimenting with you know returning to
it as spring
is dawning here in portland and um
the a
this has always been a trade-off and
frankly
we have dealt with it very very badly we
have dealt in black and white terms
across the board
right and this you know you have
for example a continuum in vulnerability
by age right that ought to be having a
dramatic effect on the way we think
about
things such as school
it ought to be having a dramatic effect
on the way we
evaluate the costs and benefits of a
novel vaccine and yet
we are not in this mindset it's like
you're either on board with the vaccine
or you're not
or you're you know you're casual about
the virus
and you want schools to open in spite of
the hazard
or um you're you know paranoid
yeah right and it's never been this way
you're either you're either in favor of
of avoiding the virus
or in avoiding economic disaster you
can't you can't be interested
in both it's not allowed by the
conversation it's not allowed by the
conversation and any of us who are
trying to do this carefully
know that it is the conversation it has
always been the conversation
and to the extent that the conversation
is ruled out in favor of a choice
between two things that are can't
possibly be right
um we are you know we are setting
ourselves up for a disaster
and i will say you know of uh
we have been pointing to this from the
beginning
we have been we've been right about a
lot but i think we have been
this is the thing that we are most right
about and have been most consistent in
trying to alert people to the danger is
that they are blocking themselves off
from normal human interactions and that
is
only going to accelerate the process of
us going
insane and that you as an individual
have a certain amount you can do
right a lot you can do but it involves
figuring out how to you know how to
reduce the harm of the trade-off itself
right so for example yesterday i saw a
group of young people
gathered in a way that young people do
not typically gather
they were they had clearly all ridden
their bikes somewhere which was
nice enough to see young young how old
late teenagers okay
they had ridden their bikes somewhere
and they were decidedly
sitting in a circle in which they were
socially distant and they were being
teenagers together
wow mixed sex what mixed sex uh they
were
uh i would say it was two-thirds boys
but it was
next yeah but anyway the point is
there's a
there's a there's a way and it's out
there and all you need to do is be tuned
into a finer level of detail about what
this threat is and
how it works and how it doesn't work and
the point is okay
hey there's a loophole right how do we
use that loophole
you know there's a way for those of us
in the northern hemisphere
again almost after
many months of ever colder wetter worse
weather
right so you know we happen to be having
a couple of just glorious days here in
in portland and it's you know it feels
now for those you know for those of us
just in the pacific northwest like
the weather has turned not such that
we're about to hit those you know two
and a half months of glorious perfect
weather that everyone else wishes they
had
um which won't come until like you know
maybe mid july
um but that we are now hitting that
intermittent phase where it's not just
going to be you know really wet and cold
with
you know occasionally a sun break but
you know we're gonna increasingly get
more and more days like the the ratio of
beautiful days
as it gets warmer and warmer and warmer
and bluer and bluer and bluer
to days that you wouldn't really be
sitting socially distance outside
is going to go up well but still the
loophole
isn't it's great go use it the loophole
is
make dopamine while the sun shines and i
like that
you know we were we were warning people
before winter
winter is coming and yes that's a joke
but it's also
not a joke and i think the thing is what
you want
you know it's like you have a an account
and the account is drained as you are
isolated from the things that actually
calibrate you and matter and that is
filled up
every time you are able to go
participate in those things and the fact
you know we didn't know
if the um failure of kova to transmit
outdoors would endure
we still don't know but so far it seems
to have so far it's enduring
so as long as it endures the point is
how
weird that 98 of the space
on or in your city 98
of the space is probably safe right and
you're not thinking of it that way
and in fact i'm stuck when i go out and
i
use our rails to trails bike path and i
see therefore lots and lots of people
something like half of them are wearing
masks whether they're
biking or walking or whatever they're
doing
and i don't know for sure some of them
you know if two people are walking side
by side and they don't live together
then maybe they're doing it because
they're you know it's probably more
caution than i think is necessary given
the evidence about outdoors
but there's a defense of it on the other
hand
if you're riding along and you're not
riding with anybody then the point is
well you're not making as much vitamin d
as you'd be making
right you need more sun exposure you
need a break from the sense that
everything is about coveted at all
moments and the fact of
something touching your face is can't be
mentally healthy i will um so we've
talked about this before
and it was last summer the last time
that we were biking together but you've
been on your bike a lot
um and i think the four of us you and me
and our boys were out on a different
uh different trail system um coming back
from sort of
deep uh southeast portland at one point
and we also saw a lot of people on bikes
with masks and were wondering uh
what that's about and i think um
i think there's effectively no chance
that if you are biking
alone you can get covered yup if you're
not masked
and so the wearing masks on bikes
is you know i i agree with you
that it is going to be you know
unnecessary but that
if you are biking hard if you are
breathing hard
and you pass someone close it is
it is more likely than if you weren't
breathing hard that you could transmit
to that person it's one factor yeah
out of many and i i would love to know
whether anybody at
all has actually contracted covid from
such a scenario right and if it is
if some have it's a tiny fraction and
how much better off would how much more
bike riding would get done and therefore
how much more
sanity would be retained if people
weren't feeling like they had to do it
in
in uh you know active coveted prevention
mode
yes but um but anyway the
uh the question that i have so i have
the sense i look at these people and i
have this
urge because of the kind of person i am
and have been
all along i have this urge i want to
talk to each of them and i want to say
do you know that you probably don't need
to be doing that
right and of course that would be a
disaster many many times and sometimes
it would get a proper response
but i the problem is i think we're
involved in a story out there
right and the story is the good people
and the bad people and you can recognize
them by their masks and therefore
the point is you wouldn't want to take
advantage of the fact that you don't
need the mask
under many outdoor circumstances because
then you would signal you're part of the
bad people and nothing's worse than that
and so
what i'm hoping is that somehow
those of us who get this and those of us
who get how much harm there is
from masks when you don't need them how
much advantage there is in feeling
normal about anything at all during
covid
right given all of that what we need is
some sort of
signal that i'm not wearing my mask now
but it isn't because i don't take that
as very very important
right i want something you know i feel
like i should be wearing something that
says i'm a covet hawk but i'm not
wearing my mask that's not needed here
right and of course that's too much but
um
but somehow we need to create that
culture of people who
do get the danger take it very seriously
and maybe that's even why they're out on
a given day that because you
you need the normalcy in order to retain
your sanity in such
such crazy times indeed
well lots lots more to say about um the
tensions
and uh you know to have to have the
words
the story of this teacher whose partner
died of kovid
and whose cherished student died of
suicide
within a week of one another um due to
the uh political measures put in place
to prevent
covid uh is remarkable
and you know maybe maybe we'll just let
that sit yeah
i agree i didn't mean to detour but i
know um but
it's it's now your turn to talk about uh
cancellation well i think we're gonna
skip that i think in light of
uh of all we've talked about i don't
think it belongs here we can talk about
it uh
another time okay um
was there more on our list because i do
have a you had uh it was possible you
were gonna say something with polar
bears but it's not necessary
and then you had just a couple things at
the very end that you wanted to say
yeah okay so maybe we should move to
polar bears how many polar bears
um i let me see um
[Music]
let me pull it up um
i did not fully prepare on this one
here we go
zachary um published in animal behavior
this last
week i think polar bear foraging on
common idear eggs
estimating the energetic consequences of
a climate-mediated behavioral shift
okay that's that's all i got um
the this is just another piece of new
research
and an idea is a duck it's a c-duck
and most people will be surprised to
hear that polar bears eat duck eggs
i know that i am quite surprised yeah so
it's like it would need to eat a lot of
them exactly so
um just from the conclusion our results
indicate that a small number of polar
bears can gain energy in late june and
early july by foraging on common idea
eggs when marine foraging opportunities
are no longer available
while our results suggest that some
bears can profit energetically from
foraging on eggs
the overall contribution that bears oh
that idea eggs make to an entire
population appears small
reinforcing the importance of seal
hunting on ice the overall persistence
of polar bears
so you know the main message here is
that as sea ice melts
and polar bears can't go out onto it in
order to find the breathing holes of the
seals which are their usual diet
they have to look to other things and
one of the things they're looking to is
duck eggs of all things which yes they'd
have to eat a lot and indeed
optimum optimal foraging theory
uh predicts and they find that early in
the season when there are a lot of eggs
the bears a few bears manage to
make a profit a metabolic profit off of
the eggs but
the you know the longer the bears are
there and the fewer the eggs there are
um the more pointless the effort gets
because they spend more resource
searching for
than the calories would return if they
find them
so there's some ambiguity here because
marine forging behavior has two meanings
right it has the one you described and
it also can mean in the case of polar
bears
uh foraging on marines yes which uh we
don't know them to do at least um
in this particular place they're very
nutritious but they're also somewhat
dangerous to hunt and so
it has not been a widespread behavior in
polar bears as i understand it marines
fight back more than duck eggs do
that is almost i mean you know what do
the data say
very good question right you'd have to
run an experiment
of course of course you would you might
want to do an observational study for
that
yep yeah all right well it's interesting
i have long wondered what is going to
happen to the polar bears
if um warming continues
well so i mean one of the things this
proposes and you know of course anyone
who's thought deeply about ecology knows
this but that there will be cascading
effects right that you know the
uh eider eggs um or other marine
other other eggs of um mass nesting
birds uh that happen to live within the
range of polar bears
uh are not likely to be able to sustain
a functional polar bear population for
very long
but um but the polar bears will eat them
until they're gone which means you'll
have those populations crashing
as well and you know having having
crashed those populations the bears will
move on to something else until
they can't find enough to eat at all and
they just they just die
well i don't know if you'll remember
this i i uh advanced a hypothesis many
years ago which i still
believe likely um having advanced it
does not mean i believe it is likely but
in this case
i advanced it and i believe it is likely
even though others will regard it as
reason to dismiss me which is that i
think there is a real
chance that polar bears will effectively
disappear into brown bears
if the the habitat that they are adapted
to
is no longer available and that in fact
um
there may be a mechanism for such things
that would involve
the collection of adaptive discoveries
over in polar bear space by brown bears
um that would manifest as
effectively regarding the uh the exotic
looking bear as sexy
you know that the brown bears might find
the
um the polar bear that knows the things
about how you deal with the poles when
they're
uh frozen or or the other way around in
which case now we know one of the gifts
that the polar bears who are finding the
brown very sexy would bring
duck eggs duck eggs yes as a
as a little nuptial gift right a
delicacy
sure no it uh yeah it's actually scale
wise it's like caviar
it's excellent um
yeah that's that's all i got on polar
bears all right well that was great um
i'm
you know nature is just amazing am i
wrong you're not wrong
i'm not wrong all right so i think the
we've got two orders of business left
to to take care of one is a correction
oh actually
actually sorry why don't we show the
thumbnail picture first just to wrap
that up before you do your two orders
okay sure um so did you send it to sang
i also yes i did and i have
i have a couple in a sequence i have it
zach here on my screen if you want to
show it if that's easier no zach why
don't you show the sequence
so uh long time viewers will
know that i've been keeping track of
a pair of bald eagles this is actually
not one of them this is from a second
pair that i've now
figured out where they live and have
been
watching them and i'm learning a
tremendous amount about watching
uh eagles and how they behave because
actually you pick up a ton just
simply spending spending the time um
so this is this is yesterday i was lucky
enough to have one of the eagles
fly directly overhead um
here is actually that eagle on its
return
trip um and this is actually right
in you know it's not downtown portland
but it's not far from it's a
little pocket nature reserve by the
willamette river you're on the east side
here though right yep yep
and here the animal is landing this is
not the tree that it has its nest in
this is an adjacent tree that seems to
be a common pattern they have a tree
where they like to hang out and look
around and then they have the tree where
the nest
itself is maybe that's to um you know
these animals are about to lay
eggs if the eggs aren't already laid and
then they'll hatch soon and
obviously there's a danger of alerting
other animals to where the nest
is because the eggs or the chicks could
be poached
but in any case really fun to
to be watching animals that are
you know not just passing through and
getting a glimpse of them but getting a
sense of what their life is like and
spending enough time to
to see those patterns beautiful
beautiful so that will be our our
thumbnail for this week this last one
yeah and then you had yeah i've got a
correction
and the correction is i much to my
embarrassment uh said the wrong thing
about
who uh the mighty quinn the song the
mighty quinn
was by i said the beatles
and i asked um
yeah that's not a very good quality
picture but here's a um
picture of manfred mann and it's
um i don't know if it's a single
or an album that is titled mighty quinn
but anyway here's man for man the famous
version
of of the mighty quinn that we
all know those of us who know it is
indeed manford
but weren't they even covering it yes
they were
now but they were not covering it from
the beatles they were covering it from
bob dylan
bob dylan was the author and apparently
the story is that bob dylan wrote it and
recorded it as a basement tape
and manfred mann released a cover of it
before dylan's
was ever heard publicly i think and so
in any case we associate it with manford
man even though it is a bob dylan
creation but i will say the reason that
there's
in some ways no excuse you feel terrible
i feel
real i don't usually do this i don't
very careful about music i'm
i treat lyrics very carefully and um
having casually accused the beatles of
invoking the word eskimo feels terrible
but i will point out they not cover it
as well
i find no evidence that they did okay i
looked
doesn't mean there isn't some cover of
it out there but it's at least not a
commonly
uh heard one but i will point out in
this photograph zach you want to put the
photograph up
in this photograph the
gentleman on the far right has clearly
borrowed john lennon's glasses there's
no doubt
why i made the error that i did so and
yet
apparently you couldn't count
i thought that was pete best on the far
left i see i see you know it's been a
while since i've seen pete and
didn't recognize that man like him but
uh anyway yes i thought that was pete
best
and uh anyway um apology
over excuse delivered in
such as it is um all right so yes all
right
and the final thing was oh yes
um i have not too surprisingly
not heard from ibram x kendi who i very
much
want to come to darkhorse and talk to me
about his framework for anti-racism
which i believe
is incorrect and i believe he should
talk to me about it if he wishes to
defend it it's far better than doing
what he seems to be doing he has uh not
responded to coleman hughes
i would actually expect him to take up
that offer more readily than ours but
nonetheless i would like him to come
on darkhorse and the reason is this i
believe his
framework for anti-racism his claim that
there is
only racism and anti-racism and not
racist is
not a category that that claim
is demonstrably false many people have
said so but i believe it is demonstrably
false at the level
of a logical proof that is so compelling
that he will
in the aftermath of the delivery of that
proof have no choice
but to either acknowledge that his
framework is wrong or ignore it
because there's no argument he could
deliver that will counter it now i would
like to invite him if he
truly believes in his framework and we
don't know if he does but if he truly
believes in his framework
i believe the right thing to do is to
come
and face that critique and then we'll
have it out and i promise
uh to be you know my usual
self i will listen to what he has to say
if he's right i will acknowledge that
he's right and that's a big win for him
so in any case next week if we have not
heard from ibrahim kennedy i will
deliver
um that proof and i believe everybody
will agree on
hearing it that it has to be right it's
that simple and that clear
so promised for next week in in less
and less uh conversation with candy is
in the works by then yeah
unless we've heard from him all right
well um
we have i guess a few announcements as
usual
uh we're going to take for those of you
tuning in on youtube a 15-minute break
and we'll be back
to answer your questions that you
opposed in super chat afterwards
please again join us at one or both of
our patreons on either of them you can
get access to the discord server
and on mine access to a two hour monthly
private q and a's
and on brett's uh to our couple of
two-hour conversations
uh that are not recorded but uh that are
wonderful active been going on for a few
years now
right with some regulars and a few new
people um
yep and we have um
we have merchandise for sale at
store.darkhorsepodcast.org we do intend
to get some new stuff out
soon please consider emailing
darkhorse.moderator gmail.com with any
logistical questions about anything that
we've said here
and um you can find uh clips
i imagine soon there will be clips uh
from
your conversation which i'm sure was
amazing although i have not listened to
it yet with jordan peterson
which uh went up last week on the clips
channel
uh darkhorse podcast clips on youtube uh
soon
and um i have i have taken to
recommending
that you you know love the people
who you should be loving and eat good
food and go outside and in light of
today i want to add
you know be barefoot and be outside
barefoot and dig in the dirt with your
hands and get your actual
hands dirty and you know feel feel
what the earth and the water of the
earth has to offer and don't just
experience it if you can if you live in
any situation where you can
don't just experience it through uh
through
shoes and through gloves but you know
actually
actually revel in the thing that is this
planet that we live on
be barefoot eat duck eggs
all right be well
you